asteroids Earth's
Nemesis they've blitzed our world for
billions of
years this takes a few seconds to create
50,000 years ago was a very bad day for
anybody living nearby yet asteroids are
also a valuable
resource giant Boulders rich with
valuable
Metals icy miniature worlds with more
fresh water than
Earth ultimately asteroids may be a
stepping song by which we can one day
leave the entire solar system asteroids
are Planet Builders without them our
world would not be
here we owe our very existence to these
things they are the givers and takers of
[Music]
life
the night sky is full of stars galaxies
planets and
asteroids asteroid actually means
starlike even in the very best
telescopes they look like nothing more
than just points of light in the in the
sky they're Cosmic
Boulders and there are trillions of them
from the size of a car to Giant
hundreds of miles
across together they tell the story of
how we came to
be the Earth was made by
asteroids 4 and2 billion years
ago the solar system is a vast Cosmic
Whirlpool dust sticks together to create
asteroids in our own solar system and in
every solar system the first objects to
form the first large rocks before
planets form are essentially
asteroids there are no planets
yet instead trillions of rocks and
stones swirl around the newly born
Sun it would have been a very strange
place kind of like a mer around of all
these objects orbiting around around the
Sun and there are millions of these
asteroids that are just in different
sizes and different
shapes these ancient asteroids will
shape the solar
system and build the planet we live
on asteroids are so much more than just
rocks in space they're the building
blocks of our very own
planet to make a planet billions of
small asteroids must Clump together
but asteroids move at thousands of miles
an
hour getting them to stick together is
hard we're here at the stock car RAC see
what the early solar system may have
looked
like highspeed car collisions cause
damage Parts smash off
asteroid collisions are the
same to join together somehow they must
Collide and
stick stock cars show us how this
happens they move fast but all in the
same
direction just like the asteroids in the
early solar
system when collisions
happen they're re relatively
gentle instead of Smashing
apart they join
together these are planets in the
making they're going around almost at
the same speed and they begin to stick
together and that's how planets begin to
[Music]
form asteroids gather into rock piles
like two cars locked
[Music]
together
as more and more asteroids Collide the
rock piles
grow building whole planets this way
would take billions of
years yet the planets formed in just a
few million
years how when the rock piles reach
Mountain size gravity speeds up the
process gravity started to become
important when they they were about the
size of one of the Rocky Mountains like
Pike's Peak behind me it was when they
were several miles across that they had
enough mass that their gravity could
start to draw material in now if the
Earth weren't here and it were just
Pikes Peak over there a few miles away I
would very slowly start to drift toward
it faster and faster accelerating the
whole way until I actually impacted it
the gravity would draw me in it would
pull on me until I actually hit the
mountain
itself
large asteroids are mountains in
Space the early solar system is full of
them their gravity pulls other asteroids
toward
them the larger an asteroid
becomes the more rocks it pulls
in and the faster it
grows at that point the events happen
very quickly it would actually draw that
stuff in and grow very
rapidly one of these early space
mountains keeps on
growing until there are no rocks left to
pull
in it's no longer an
asteroid it's a young Planet the
Earth all of the planets even the Earth
they owe their existence to the fact
that there were asteroids back
then
this is how all rocky planets
form asteroids join together until there
are no more
[Music]
left
Mercury
Venus Earth
Mars are all overgrown
[Music]
asteroids but beyond Mars something went
wrong no rocky planets instead
billions of rocks and boulders that
never join
together the asteroid
belt out here construction came to a
halt before a rocky planet could form
because of
Jupiter the gas giant had already formed
nearby Jupiter is human humongous it's
the 800 PB gorilla it dominates
everything
gravitationally 42 billion years ago
Jupiter's gravity causes
Havoc it flings asteroids in every
direction giant Boulders scatter from
their regular orbits onto extreme
chaotic
paths the stock car race ends and the
demolition derby
begins once Jupiter got involved the
solar system began to look like a
demolition derby things colliding with
each other going in all sorts of
different
directions a cosmic pileup rocks smash
into each other from every
direction violent chaotic
collisions these rocks don't Clum
together they
shatter and create the asteroid
belt violent collisions Still Rock the
asteroid belt
today in 2010 the Hubble Space Telescope
captured
[Music]
this the aftermath of a hypervelocity
collision asteroids can both create
and
Destroy if many of them come together
gently you get
planets too much violence and you get
the asteroid
belt billions of rocks and boulders a
graveyard for a planet that never
formed the asteroid belt is a mysterious
realm full of Danger full of
promise a new frontier just waiting to
be
[Music]
explored asteroids are as diverse as
planets or
moons some are
metallic some
rocky some
Icy
some even have their own
moons they come in all shapes and
sizes from Boulders all the way to
miniature
[Music]
worlds and they are
everywhere distant solar systems have
their own asteroid
belts the star Epsilon a Donnie is just
10 light years
away it has not one but two asteroid
belts another star has a belt 25 times
larger than our
own if you're actually living on a
planet in that solar system the asteroid
belt would look like a much brighter
than the Milky Way a big streak across
the night
sky asteroid belts or scraps left over
after the planet planets have
formed so they tell us a lot about their
solar
system our asteroid belt is full of
variety millions of strange
[Music]
asteroids each with a story to
tell yet we've barely explored it at
[Music]
all that's about to
change
the first mission to the asteroid belt
is underway the dawn
[Music]
probe its goal to explore a mysterious
distant
[Music]
realm we're going to learn more about
the main belt asteroids from this one
Mission than we will have since we've
discovered the asteroid belt in the
first
place in July 2011 Dawn arrived at its
Target
and sent back these
pictures Vesta is the second largest
asteroid in the
belt it almost became a
planet then Jupiter's massive gravity
stunted its
growth today it's a miniature world one
of the common misconceptions about the
asteroid belt is that things are fairly
small but some of the largest asteroids
are really more correctly thought of as
minor planets they're several hundred
miles
across Vesta even has a mountain three
times higher than
Everest Mark Sykes is a co-investigator
of the
mission it's just a real excitement
because you're seeing a new world for
the first time and and and you know just
enough to be dangerous and trying to
explain what it is that you're
seeing Vesta is like a snapshot of the
infant earth when it was no wider than
[Music]
Arizona we're seeing perhaps what an
embryonic early terrestrial planet like
Earth looked like in the in the first
few million years of its
history the dawn probe has already found
that Vesta has an iron core like the
Earth evidence that the Earth's core
formed when the planet was still
young this stunted World offers us a
window on the Earth's distant
past we're seeing things that we didn't
necessarily expect but that's what makes
it
fun after Vesta the dawn Mission will
head into the asteroid belt's outer
reaches to explore an ice primeval
world four times bigger than
Vesta there Dawn aims to settle another
mystery about the Earth's
past the oceans where did they come
[Music]
from